research shows at 15 hours we see growth
hormone go up growth hormone is the
hormone that keeps you young and helps
you burn fat we also see in men
1300% increase in testosterone just from
somewhere between a 13 to 15 hour fast
and then we start to see inflammation go
down so all of a sudden if you have
people who have like joints that are
hurting they start doing 15 hours of
fasting every day and they're like God
you know my joints just don't have that
same skin stiffness in them anymore but
if you stay in that fasted window you
keep going 17 hours your brilliant body
turns within and it goes wait a second
no food's coming in we better get
stronger so it literally takes this the
bad cells the cells that are slowing you
down the cells that are turning into
cancer and it gets rid of those they're
called ccent cells and it it literally
recycles them out of your system and it
goes into the cells that are still
usable and it makes them stronger